Hello everybody, this is Dr. Connors and this Zoom session, this recording, it's going
to be about a serious spiritual matter when we come to wanting to be healed, that I think
we need to address and just keep our focus to make sure that we keep our focus on the right
things.
We all want healing when we're sick, we have cancer, we have serious disease, we have
Lyme, we have ALS, Parkinson's and all sorts of problems in this world. And we can ask
serious questions and I think you're called to do that. When we go through the grieving process
of understanding that we are mortal and our life is not to be lived completely on this
earth, it gets a little scary, but where in our 20s we think we're going to live forever.
And as we get older and we start having serious diagnoses, then that reality hits in. And many times
we turn to God and that's a blessing. We're supposed to turn to God in times of crisis.
But we have to be careful that we don't turn to God just to get what we want.
Yes, we're supposed to ask for what we want and the Bible is very clear that you don't receive
because you don't ask. But it's also very clear that we're supposed to ask with the right heart
and we're supposed to accept God's answer. Paul made it very clear that he asked for his
thorn of his side to be taken away three times, he said, which I find it kind of funny because
I probably asked for my thorns to be taken away 575 times at least. And I don't fully understand
that passage why he would only ask three times. But maybe it was three different periods of his life
where he was intense prayer about whatever that thorn be in illness, a deformity, whatever it is,
we don't know. And he was intensely in prayer and got the answer from God that it wasn't going to
be taken away and he let it go for a period of time and then took it up another period of time.
And there's a time and a season for everything and we're called to do that. And we need to be
fervent in our prayer and fervent in our asking. And I think we need to ask for healing. I'm praying
for healing for all of you and for myself on a daily basis. But we have to keep it in balance.
First of all, biblically is healing promised. We can pull up verses all through the Bible where
healing was promised to a certain person, to a certain people group and to us as believers as whole.
So healing is for us in the new covenant. God did come to heal all our wounds and all our diseases.
But that doesn't mean that they're going to be healed this side of heaven. If that was true,
every believer from the New Testament on would still be alive. And that's not true.
All the apostles suffered and died for his sake. Many were brutally bartered. And to think that we
have the right to not go down that same pathway is pompous, arrogant and just absolutely foolish.
If we want to serve our Savior, we need to be willing to die in the flesh just as our Savior did.
Paul said, oh, that I may encompass the same sufferings that my Lord Jesus did, that he could
know him more fully. And that's going to be our desire of our heart as well, not that we run around by
like Vasekis wanting to be tortured for God. But if we're not willing to suffer for his namesake,
we have to really question where we are with our relationship with him. Though we're supposed to ask
for a healing, we're supposed to be praying for healing and praying for all the things that we need
in our life, they cannot be more important than our relationship with him. And as I write in
my book, Kids or Kid Kill You, if you're already dead, our first and foremost prayer has got to be
asking God to put his desires in our heart. What do you want me to pray for, Lord?
Maybe God's got me with this sickness so that I'll get out my knees and get closer to him and ask
him what he wants me to pray for instead of just praying selfish prayers. I'm always speaking for
myself, this is just my walk and I can encourage you through my walk about telling you what to do,
but I know that's how God deals with me. He gives me sufferings to break me. He gives me
sufferings to deal with strongholds in my life so that I can turn it over to him more readily because
I fall every day. I think I can do it myself every day and through my sufferings is how I learn
obedience. Through my struggles I learn obedience. And that is my prayer every day, Lord, what do you
need me to pray for? What do you need me to do? How do you need me to pray? Who do you need me to ask
for help for? Because this isn't about me. Life is not about me. Life is not about me. Be healthy and
rollerblading when I'm 85 years old and living this wonderful life. What good is that? What's the
importance of that? That is not supposed to be our God in our life and that's what we have to
be careful about. We need to be asking what is the will of God for me? God, what do you want for me
to do? If I've surrendered myself to be His, it's not about me anymore. That's done. It's not about
me anymore. I've surrendered myself to Him. And if I have truly surrendered myself to Him and it's a
daily basis, it's a daily walk. I understand that. It doesn't just happen one second in time. That's
what sanctification is all about. Is Him chiseling away the rough edges of me to mold me and shape me
daily more to be like the image of His Son and it's a painful process. And I need to be willing to
go through that pain. It's easy to say that, but when I'm in the middle of that pain, I need to be
reminded of that. So that is what the will of God is for me. Not for me to live to be 95 years old
and have us wonderful life and have a 401k and be able to golf every day. It's wonderful if you could
do that. Don't get me wrong. But you need to be asking, is that the will of God for me? How can
I serve you? How can I get to the end to hear those faithful words? Well done, good and faithful
servant. That's my goal. And I hope that's your goal too. And that's where we have to be careful.
And I have to say some sharp words because healing or anything else can be idolatry.
If my whole focus in life is to get something from God, that's idolatry. And I know those are
tough words and I know that might slap somebody in the face, but let it. Our purpose has to be
free from idolatry. Our purpose has to be Lord, I'm your tool. Use me. However you want to use me,
whether you want to make me go through horrible things and suffer because somebody's watching me
and somebody's going to be set free because of that, Lord, let it be your will. I remember,
I think I've told you this story before. We were missionaries down in Mexico for a short period of time
and we had wet self-financed. We sold everything that we had. This is back when we were in our early 30s.
And we played a stay in three years, but see the deed down there. We taught at a Bible school
and an orphanage in Bolteray, Mexico. And we ended up building a dormitory there and I taught
at the Bible school for a year the Covenant of God. And we also worked in the Shanty towns,
down in Mexico, in the borders and in the Shanty towns in Bolteray. And we used to go back with our
suburban. We had four kids at the time. We used to drive back and we registered as missionaries with
some wonderful organizations on the other side of the border. Bolteray is about three to half hours
in from the border of Texas, South Texas. And we used to pick up about every weekend or every other
weekend. We used to pick up and load our suburban full of stuff that we were given by feed the children
international and things that they were given by different corporations and stuff that we could give
away and that we could be a blessing to the people of the Shanty towns. And we used to pull it
into the Shanty towns with our truck and I used to say with my broken Spanish, everybody light up and
we would share a message of Jesus Christ and we would give people things and we would go around to
their little places and talk to them about the Lord as best we could. And they were also gracious
because they were all want to be Americans and so everybody was so kind to us and we'd ever felt
even in the worst situations that we were threatened or we were a danger in any way that we probably were,
we just trusted the Lord that was going to take care of us. But I remember coming back from there
after we left after a little over a year we were down there. We just completely ran out of funds and
we could not raise money to stay down there anymore and we had really no choice but to come back.
And my wife and two youngest had my father flew them back up from South Texas and I was driving back
with my two older daughters. They were their early teens or a little bit younger at the time.
And we had nothing. We had zero money, not one penny left. And I was pulling our suburban and I had
just enough gas money to get home. And we had rented a U-Haul, a little TD U-Haul trailer. We were
pulling that because we had purchased some mattresses and a bunk bed down there. We didn't want to
give that up so we brought that back with us. So all our worldly possessions were the suburban in
this little U-Haul trailer. Pull it back and I just remember the girls were sleeping and I was
just crying out to the Lord because we didn't have a job. We didn't have, I didn't have my
care. Practic license that couldn't practice anymore. I had given that up and it's crying out to the
Lord because I felt like the best we could describe all our work down there was that we were putting
drops of water into a bucket that had no bottom. That's what I felt like. What did we do
anything to make a difference? We toiled and worked day and night and I just felt like we didn't do
anything to make a difference. And it was one of those moments that I felt like I really heard from
the Holy Spirit directly to my heart. And he said, if I would have had you do this all over again
for just one person would you do it? And that was a ginormous slap in the face to me because it was
a revelation that God would send his son to go to the cross for just me or just one person and suffer
everything that he suffered to take on the sins of the world for my salvation alone. If it was only
for me why wouldn't I do that for him for just one person? And it's just a revelation that it's not
about me. It's not about my stuff. It's not about my purpose and it's so easy especially in America
to become so idolatrous to things and to thinking that we have the right to even health who says I have
the right to health. A kind of warped sense of understanding is that we have the right to health.
It is by a miracle of God that I am breathing today. There's a miracle that my heart is beating.
It is said to be thankful for that I'm widened because oh my gosh I might have two months
to live or eight months to live or two years to live. You could never have been promised two
seconds to live. Praise God that he's given me today and yet we worry so much about tomorrow.
Jesus said to Peter let the days old troubles be enough for today and I need to learn that.
The problem is really honestly it's who we put our faith in that makes a difference. The problem is
most of the time I have my faith in what? In me getting better that's what my faith is. My faith is in
me carrying cancer. My faith is in this right-fishing working or my nutrition working. My faith is in
is in my relationships being good. My faith is that my 401K is still healthy and that the economy is
going to stay up. That's the wrong thing to have our faith in. It's a faith in who? That's who we have
to have our faith in. It's our faith in Jesus Christ that he is enough. There's a story in the
Bible of a woman who is bleeding for a decade or so and sick and it has been to her life savings going
to doctors and Jesus was walking through a crowd being touched by everybody reaching out,
wanting something from him. Jesus, Jesus, heal me, heal me. The apostles I can imagine were pushing
the p- crowds back and a woman crawled underneath everybody and thought if I could just touch his
garment because he has everything I need. He is everything I need and she rubbed her hand along
his garment as he walked by and healing went out from him and healed her. An crazy thing in the
midst of this crowd. Jesus turns around to his apostles and says who touched me? I'm sure the
apostles are like, are you freaking out of your mind? Lord, I mean everybody's touching you were smashed
in this crowd. Everybody's screaming. What do you mean who touched you? What do you mean who touched
you? Somebody touched me. Somebody touched me and he turns around. Who touched me? Who touched me?
And here, left of the ground, this is woman crouched, looking up, shy,
uninvited wondering, am I going to get you all that? She said, Lord, it was I. And he said,
your faith has healed you. Does that mean your faith in being healed? Does that mean your faith in
being cured? I don't believe so. I believe it was her faith in Jesus Christ. Her faith that he was
everything he was all she needed whether she was going to be healed or not. She was all he was all she
needed. And that's where we need to be. God is all I need whether I get healed or I don't get healed.
It's not about this world. This is not my home. I want to go home, I long for eternity. I long to
spend eternity in heaven just getting to know my Savior more and more forever and ever and ever and ever.
That's how vast the knowledge of God is. None of us could even understand or grasp the depth
with the breath of the knowledge of God that we're going to gain in eternity. That's what I
long for. Yes, do I want to be healed? Sure. Do I want to spend some time with my grandkids and my
children and my wife? Absolutely. But not more than I want to spend with my Savior. And if it is ever
more than I want to spend with my Savior, they are an idol in my life. And Lord, may that never be.
That needs to be our prayer. Lord, make you all I need, Heavenly Father.
Just whatever you need to put me through so that you are all I need and you are my desire
of my heart. Lord, we thank You in Jesus' name. Amen.